What's up guys?
We're back in the lab today with a water bottle a blowtorch a box of matches
and an oversized Martini glass
Because DhArshan [Mizuki] wants to know
what would happen if we tried freezing gasoline than lighting it on fire
Freezing gasoline and liquid nitrogen is [one] of my highest requested
videos right [now]
and this comment got over 418 likes in one hour
that's why we're doing it today.
Will frozen gasoline burn?
That's the question we're here to answer today.
I want to tell you about my water bottle.
Yes, this actually is my water bottle, but just a few minutes ago
I ran down to the gas station
and filled it up with 91 Octane Premium Gasoline
The Octane rating refers to how much pressure
the gasoline can take before igniting
and I got the highest stuff we get
Now we know that gasoline in its normal state is a liquid and it's highly combustible
It's extremely flammable and it's what we use to run our vehicles
If we pour a bit of it onto my brick here and light it off, you can see it goes up in flames
The question though becomes what will happen to frozen gasoline?
Gasoline has a freezing point anywhere between
-40 to minus -50 Fahrenheit and Celsius
So we could probably use liquid propane liquid butane or anything else like [that] to freeze it
but for quickness and convenience in this project
[I'm] going back to my old friend liquid nitrogen
So first things first we need to transfer our liquid nitrogen into our giant Martini glass and hopefully it doesn't break as we do
[alright], that's enough to make [you] feel [uncomfortable] here comes, the boil. This is my favorite part whoa. Oh
If that glass let's go to spill all over the workbench. It's cracked like crazy on the bottom there
It's working its way up like [spiderwebs]. Oh, no, oh
It's [all] spilling down the side here. Look at this look [at] this. We've got a leak
That's not good
Our martini glass has turned into a spiderweb of cracks that didn't really take very long and honestly I wasn't expecting anything different
But that is [$13] down the drain
Okay, I am going to see if I can salvage any of this nitrogen here
So liquid nitrogen in a Martini glass not so much
[alright] at Em number two ceramic Ball
Look at the way it boils up around the edges. It's jumping to get out of the Bowl
[all] [right] guys. It looks like our liquid nitrogen has sufficiently cooled
What's really interesting it takes so much nitrogen to cool the dish down?
We lose more [than] half of the ball just in the cooling process alone now
You know that nitrogen itself is not flammable you can demonstrate that by dipping and match into it here
You can see the match goes out as soon as it hits that top layer of nitrogen
The time has come to add our [gasoline] and what I'm thinking [is] we'll just pour a few drops in there and see what happens
Here we go. Oh
Wow
Interesting look how dense that vapour is it turned white and came out like a mushroom cloud and if I push that away you can
actually see
The Gasoline is floating on top of [the] nitrogen right there that's interesting. [it's] still liquid it hasn't frozen yet
It's almost like it's got a protective coating around it
But there, it's starting to get hard now perfect. We've got a very small sample size here
I'm pretty comfortable with [let's] go ahead and pull that out and light it off
There we go my friends that is frozen guessing. I'm actually going to pour a little bit more in there
That is so cool. I've never seen this before. I wasn't expecting such a rich white fog
Look at that
It's like a gasoline slushy well
It's actually like solidified in to a bunch of globs of gasoline
The thing that's really interesting to me about this is how white the gasoline is
I thought it would have more of a yellowish tinge to it, but that's pretty clear pretty white
Very impressive, what happens if I pull one of these pieces out?
The Gasoline Melts extremely quickly, so I'm dipping my tongs in here to cool them down
And that'll give us a little bit more time to [work] [with] this stuff
Well hold them in the tongs light the edge and see [what] happens here we go
Frozen gasoline versus fire in three two one
whoa
interesting
So I don't know if you noticed that but the second the two made contact it's piddled and almost exploded
I saw kind of like almost look like white flames that happen very fast
But it definitely lit off and as the flames grew it melted all [the] gasoline and just burn much normal that was interesting
Let's do some more
three two one
Amazing so [we'll] frozen gasoline burn apparently it does and takes off with a very very vigorous ignition
So for this next experiment thinking let's just scoop up a bunch of chunks on a frozen spoon like this and touch a match to
The top and see what they do when they're all congregated together hMM gasoline super
Cool here we go
Holy heck that was bigger scoop my bench [workbenches] on fire
here's the best part little nitrogen Vapor Waterfall
Battle of the Elements hot versus cold hot is winning. Let's try at the base
Our nitrogen fire extinguisher. It's pretty cool
So did you see how vigorous that reaction was like the second I put the flame into the spoon it would just pop crackle Pop
Crackle and it just went crazy almost explosive. Which is very interesting so I think at this point
It's pretty much confirmed frozen gasoline does burn even at the temperatures of liquid nitrogen?
[what's] really interesting is how much energy it still has that those cryogenic temperatures? Let's do it again
It's [spitz]
And then the rest turns to gel gel gasoline quick use the nitrogen fire extinguisher. [oh]
Look at that
We got a river of nitrogen flowing through the center of a valley of fire
I'm just playing with it a little I could put it out if I wanted to
Whoa, that's [clean]
wait again, sit down
That's some [nudes]
So for this last experiment I going to try pouring a whole bunch of gasoline in at once to see if we can freeze one
Big Giant Solid chunk
That's quite a bit
You can see little bubbles and spats of gasoline freezing. It almost freezes like ice
And that looks really cool. You know one thing
I'm thinking what would happen if you took a match and threw it in
To the [gasoline] and nitrogen combined would it even light off but with the nitrogen vapor suppress the ignition?
If it does go off it's going to be a pretty dramatic display I
Don't know what's going to [happen] my guess is the flame will go out, but if it doesn't this is going to be spectacular
[here] we go. [aah]
[Aah]
Nitrogen barrier
Let's see that again. I'm a little more confident this time here comes the flame
Can't even get to the gasoline
Okay, let's do this. Let's light a little bit of gasoline up here and then put it down into the mix
And it goes out
oop
That's pretty cool
All right guys for one grand finale. We're going to light a match and throw it into this container with gasoline and nitrogen combined
There's a lot of gasoline in there, and the Pillars are just high enough. I think we can actually get them to ignite here
we go
whoa
Whoa, thanks
whoo
craziness, [oh] that's hot
Well, I do have a fire extinguisher. I don't really want to use it. I don't want to use my fire extinguisher
I'm just gonna put this out manually
Stop drop and roll, [right]. We got smother that fire. I need a wet rag. [oh] wait never mind. I'm doing okay
Hit it. Holy. Oh my goodness
[all] [right], sweet lesson learned. Well, it's actually really impressive. How well my workbench held up to all that
Super-Impressed
Might think that was stupid, but I was actually expecting that
So let's talk about what just happened here today
We start out with the purpose of trying to see whether or not frozen gasoline was night
And not only did we find that it does ignite
But it actually bursts into a very energetic flame
Next we tried freezing a spoon and scooping up multiple chunks of gasoline and placing a match down in the middle where we found that
It burst into flames spattered around all over the place
Eventually liquefying the gasoline and returning to burn like normal
We found that if you take a lit match and place it into a container of liquid nitrogen. It will go out every single time
But we also found out that if you have enough frozen gasoline in the container it can take off with such a vigorous
[reaction] that it can bypass that nitrogen layer sucking all the air that wants and caused a massive explosion
Which almost resulted in an insurance claim so in conclusion?
I [think] we can confirm that frozen gasoline will burn not only that but it burns in a way that completely blew my expectations
And of course a big thanks to DhArshan mithu [kia], and everyone else who's been requesting this experiment check your Youtube inbox DhArshan?
I'm sending you 25 bucks.
That's it guys. Thanks for joining [me] for this experiment. I'll be looking for you the next video. Talk to you then
Well that escalated quickly didn't it?
Hey guys, thanks for watching and remember. I'm giving away prizes now on every new video
All you have to do to qualify is
Subscribe to my channel ring the bell and select to be notified when my next videos get released the secret link to my giveaways [will]
Be pinned in the comments for the first [twelve] hours if you like what I'm doing show your support right now by giving this video
A big thumbs up and share with a friend. I love you back. I'll see you next time